voici le père charles boulogne on le
premier greffé du coeur en france en
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
respect à permettre un organe de l'être
cher sa position sur le don d'organes a
de quoi étonner pour l'époque encore
quelques années après en 1976 c'est une
question qui divise l'opinion
c'est au nom devrait avoir le petit
papier dans son sac devant les
autorisations vous donneriez pas
l'autorisation à la condition que les
miens soit d'accord en 1976 toujours des
médecins alertent sur la difficulté à
greffer le frein premier l'interdiction
de prélever des organes sur une personne
décédée
on ne comprend pas qu'on ne puisse pas
décédée à une époque on sait que le mort
peut servir aux vivants la loi change
fin 76 tout citoyen français désormais
un donneur présumés depuis le nombre de
greffes a nettement augmenté de quelques
centaines de transplantation dans les
années 70 on en dénombre près de 3000
par an dans les années 90 jusqu'à
atteindre plus de 6000 en 2017
mais attention car dans le même temps
les besoins de aussi grimper plus on
avance dans le temps plus l'écart se
creuse entre transplantation et greffes
en attente les jours je m'imagine ce
fameux coup de filet c'est vraiment le
cadeau précieux qu'on pourra jamais me
donnait depuis 2010 est les règles ont
changé
la famille d'un défunt ne peut plus
s'opposer au prélèvement d'organes
on va être obligé d'être beaucoup plus
directif de leur dire très clairement
votre proche n'était pas contre donc il
est pur et je vais procéder je vous
informe que je vais procéder au
prélèvement bien évidemment dans des cas
insupportable si les familles se met en
travers on ne va pas appeler la police
pour faire appliquer la loi
en 2018 le taux d'opposition au
prélèvement était de 30%
il était de 33 % en 2016 peu de chemin
donc depuis la nouvelle loi
[Musique]